Continental Tire coaches corner brings
us the head coach at Notre Dame Brian
Kelly joins us after the big win over
Michigan got Ball State coming up this
next weekend coach how are you this
morning
I'm doing great beyond do you follow the
NFL I do what do you watch who do you
watch well I used to watch the when
you're on but now that you go through
those Toyota commercials anymore I I
just given up the whole thing
I just don't busy not the same thank you
I appreciate that
do you have a favorite team well I'm
originally from Boston Massachusetts so
when I grew up I was a Patriots fan but
I've got 27 30 players in the NFL so I
kind of pick and choose I like to watch
my guys play so I'm a fan of all all the
NFL teams how often do you hear from
players in the NFL that played for you
Oh quite a bit I mean they you know they
were off last week so we probably had no
no no 20 25 30 guys back for the game
last week so it's great to touch base
with them watching tape of the Michigan
win are you looking for positives
would you look for positives first or
negatives first oh I think you look at
the positives first I mean you know
you're a teacher and an educator first
so you know you're always gonna you know
try to grade you know the positives and
then you go back and you critique it and
and you look on the things that you can
get better at going into you know the
next week but now you're always looking
for the positives and and how you can
get better you know as a football team
you know it's not a you know it's not a
final grade it's it's the first step in
a long process the day after a big win
what's that morning what was Sunday
morning like after you know all the the
hoop love the excitement of Saturday's
win over Michigan busy you know -
because today now in college football
it's wrapped around recruiting so back
up in the morning hosting parents
recruits it makes it a bit easier after
a win certainly but a full day of
balancing recruits
with you know breaking down the film
meeting with your coordinators your
medical staff you know your your
postgame show so it becomes a busy busy
you know 24 48 hours
your dad was a politician right yes and
you're a Poli Sci major in college yes
so I get the dark path right okay how
good are you at giving speeches to your
team did you learn anything from your
dad I think just being around it you get
a you know you get a sense of you know
what to say at the right moment more so
than you know a planned speech so I
think I've developed you know in my
upbringing you know what to say at the
right time because you know look you
know they're still young and they don't
need a long-winded you know talk they
need they need the right words at the
right time but do you remember a great
speech you had or at least you thought
it was a great speech you know I'll go
back to when I was a division - head
coach we were playing Texas A&M
Kingsville if Seton can get if he could
get there their mascot
he is my all-time say he's my all-time
favorite anyways because he's a Notre
Dame fan but they are the javelinas by
the way we were playing Texas A&M
Kingsville when I was at Grand Valley
State and we were on the practice field
right next to them and they were out out
of their locker room
you know cursing us out we were gonna
kick your butt you Yankees from the
north well and
yeah it was getting pretty heated and I
went up to the team pulled them together
and I said listen they're scared of you
that's why they're out here and it just
hit at the moment we went out the next
day and we beat him 35 to 7 so you know
just those timely kind of things that I
didn't know they were scared because
they look pretty big today it works they
believed it and sometimes you know you
take those shots and and they work and
in that instance it did so sometimes
your talks really have to be edgy and
and sometimes they work sometimes they
don't are you thinking about scheduling
the javelinas well I'll tell you what
once you beat a javelina you don't want
to that's it he's Brian Kelly Notre Dame
head coach Ball State is coming up this
weekend coolest thing you have in your
office is what I have a handmade samurai
sword green decked out as a Notre Dame
Mobilio pisto I do adore my Zdeno Chara
stick as one of the lengthiest sticks
ever made does he's what six eight and
then probably seven feet on skates yeah
yeah but as I look around my surfboards
pretty good because there's not a lot of
surfers here in South Bend who gave you
the surfboard the Alumni Club from the
Southern California Alumni Club of Notre
Dame oh all right good yeah yeah you got
to keep it eclectic here at South Bend
so the samurai sword really works good
with the surfboard and there's add a
note our hockey stick Continental Tire
coaches corner bringing us Brian Kelly
Notre Dame head coach I'm curious about
when you you have that big win and
everybody always expects or you have to
remind your team hey take ball skate as
serious as you did Michigan here but you
know that the kids no matter what you
say
it doesn't always resonate so how does
it work on your end to let them know do
not have a letdown well because we've
been down this road many many times
before with the
schedule that we play and that each and
every week you know there's there's high
expectations there so step set a
standard way before the season starts a
standard of play what our expectations
are and how we should play this game
each and every week so you know practice
the same way set the same standards a
faceless opponent and and this is how we
play and demand these expectations each
and every week whether it's Ball State's
and to build Michigan and and really
operate that way because if you try to
play to the opponent that you're playing
you you're gonna get different
expectations how many games did you
coach against Le'Veon Bell I think two
two games what was the game point did
you know that he was a special running
back we we thought he was you know
obviously an elite back you know when
you're when you're breaking down and
evaluating personnel you know he was a
guy that we felt was a game changer
somebody that could impact the game and
you had to have a plan he was a guy that
needed an extra hat and generally an
unblocked defender at the line of
scrimmage if things were equal he was
gonna find a way through and and be an
impact in the game best player you've
coached against his who so many great
ones kept in line Andrew Luck probably
at Stanford I mean he just was there
never seems to be a right answer against
him when he was healthy in and at the
top of his game you ever had one of
those Nick Saban moments where he just
tired of here in the same V been in that
where some of the media keeps asking you
a question wanting an answer and you're
just tired of hearing about it yeah
absolutely
you know I think that you know for me
you know I get quite a bit of scrutiny
so I have to be very careful
so really you get scrutiny oh just once
in a while so I think you have to be
very careful there's many of those
moments and you just have to take a deep
breath and and I think Nick recognizes
that as well and he's been in a long
time and you know to have his problem no
coach that he's got the backfield he's
got him at defense attack oh yeah yeah
tough life yeah go ahead I hear he
bumped me last week for the for my slot
I thought I was supposed to be in that
slide you bumped me for Nick Saban
Francine told me he called me by the way
it's not see I was supposed to be yes
and I was supposed to be in that slot
and you bumped me for Nick Saban well
Saban was going through some controversy
here and I thought you guys were gonna
be Michigan I didn't know this was a big
guy that was a great that was a great
turnaround on that one hey yes well we
wanted to give coach the victory lap
here coming off a huge win on Michigan
so bumping ball said thank you very much
I appreciate yeah yeah Fritzi is that
true we cannot confirm coach don't screw
it up against Ball State we appreciate
your time as always
thank you take care dad all right Brian
Kelly Notre Dame head coach Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
who do Seaton uh-oh pipeline there the
coach yeah yeah I got the inside sources
is there a green phone that rings when
you call it's gold it's not the repple
it's gold it's gold it's my golden dome
kind of like it's it's real gold yeah
yeah actual 24 Wow Continental Tire
Coach's Corner
cotton oldest I are proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive Continental has a tire for
you Continental Tire dot-com for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show ass
you
[Music]